thinking back to when you worked in the
mailroom so you'd gone to AFI you worked
in the mailroom there's many people
similar spot and they kind of look
around and they say how long is this
person been here oh yeah I don't want to
end up like that I want to be directing
and producing that's a common thing I
think it's a common traded youth do we
think I'm not gonna be that person forty
years old over there working there a
long time
how does someone then get out of that
because I'm sure that many of those
people in those positions they plan the
same thing but then life happens
kids happen mortgages happen and you
can't just say well I'm gonna run off
and produce this when you have a family
to support responsibilities so how
common is that idea well I mean it's
gonna be different for me I'm gonna come
here fresh out of film school or
wherever I'm not going to be that guy
over there in that department I'm gonna
make changes I think for everyone that
has a dream of being a show business
there's that moment where you start at
the very bottom at the whatever that
entry level is and it's different for
for everyone but a lot of us started in
the mailroom and for me I was having
breakfast with my grandfather who was a
very important role model in my life the
Friday before the Monday I had my first
day in the mailroom and he said to me
what are you gonna do to get noticed I
said I don't know I'll do a good job he
goes well I'm sure everyone in the mill
one wants to do a good job what are you
gonna do to be noticed as I don't know
what he goes what do you plan on wearing
I said it I don't know tee shirt pants
nice pants maybe a call a collared shirt
he goes no you're gonna wear a jacket
and tie I said in a mailroom
he said you wear a jacket and tie
whoever you're delivering mail to is
gonna look up and go who's this kid and
I got there Monday everybody was in like
torn Metallica or you know rock-and-roll
shirts and cutoff jeans and I was there
and they the day did not look kindly on
me who was this kid from film school
with the shirt and tie on and the first
day I was delivering mail to this
producer Rick Rosser who had done chips
and was doing for this company filmways
was doing a show called
two-forty Robert which was chips in
Malibu
stalling starring John Bennett Perry
Matthew Perry's dad and he looked at me
goes who are you and I said this is why
was and he goes what are you doing here
I said I'm delivering your mail and he
goes where you from and I said I just
graduated from film school he goes give
me two weeks and you're gonna work for
me two weeks later he lived up to us and
I became his assistant so I know no
change in pay but I no longer was
delivering mail I only delivered mail
for about two weeks and I was his
assistant would go around to the set and
go to production meetings and that led
me to the next job which was as a
answering phones for a casting director
who was doing rock III and a bunch of
series for ABC and then that job led me
to meet someone at ABC who said you need
to get out of the blue-collar side of
our business below the line and you need
to get above the line so I'm gonna find
you a job as a reader and so a year
later I got a job as a reader and that
started my development career do you
think that's still possible today
I think what I teach in my class at AFI
and I have young students you know in
their 20s and 30s who have the same
dream that I had when I was sitting at
AFI and I think the part of that helps
that I was i sat in the chair that they
sat in and I really believe that you
make your own good luck passion is
really important
hard work is really important respecting
the people on your way up is really
important but yes I absolutely believe
that dreams can still come true mice
I've had quite a few of my students that
have had very successful careers as
producers summer screenwriters so yeah I
don't a hundred percent believe that
there is still the chance when I
graduated from AFI the barrier to entry
was financial you couldn't just set up
shop and make a movie you couldn't set
up shop and make a short film you had to
have a 16-millimeter a 35-millimeter
camera you had to have it developed by
kodak you had to rent superb equipment
lights and sound and nagra's and
everything was expensive so nobody was
making something on their own now my
son's run a digital content
company called at phony text which is on
snapchat Facebook YouTube Instagram they
have a hundred and fifty hundred seventy
five million views on YouTube and
they've only been doing this eight
months there you have no barrier to
entry
they make write produce direct all of
their own content and they do it all
themselves in-house so they have the
advantage of making their dream come
true
they're storytellers just like I was
only there skipping the mailroom and the
because they can do it with a phone I
didn't have that luxury so I do believe
if you know Peter Guber told me that the
currency to our industry is good stories
that if you have one someone is going to
find it when Barry Morrow pitched me a
story of a two brothers one who was
mentally challenged and got inherited
all the money from his father when he
died and the brother that didn't get the
money deciding to kidnap him he was a TV
movie writer and I was a TV movie
producer and he told it to me and I knew
it was a feature and we walked across
the hall to Roger Birnbaum who was
running who were Peters features while I
was running Cooper Peters television but
we all knew was a great story you know
at the time we thought we were gonna
make it as a little tiny movie for
Warner Brothers Warner Brothers past it
ended up at UA and of course it also
ended up with Dustin Hoffman and Tom
Cruise and it became Rain Man but you
know it was a good story and it didn't
it didn't come from a highfalutin very
successful screenwriter came from a
television movie writer and didn't come
from a feature executive I was a TV
movie executive so it ya dreams come
true
you